General Stanley McChrystal knows a
little something about leadership the
retired four-star general was the
commander of US and international forces
in Afghanistan the West Point graduates
spent 34 years in the Army and is the
co-founder of the McChrystal group now
he hopes to answer the question what
makes a leader great with his new book
called leaders myth and reality he
profiles 13 leaders from company
founders like Coco Chanel two geniuses
like Albert Einstein and visionaries
like Martin Luther King jr. and Martin
Luther General McChrystal good morning
it's great to have you here thanks for
having me there are a billion leadership
books what I love about this one is you
basically say the way we've thought
about leadership is skewed it's wrong
explain why the different approach
you're taking here well I spent a
lifetime trying to learn and practice
leadership and then late in the life I
came to the realization I really don't
and so as we started this study we
really came to the understanding that
leadership is not what we think it is
and it never has been we've looked at
leadership through mythology and and
that's just colored our vision so one of
the important myths that you take on
early in the book to set the template
for the way you look at this is the
famous painting of George Washington
Crossing the Delaware River so the
famous painting that we all know he's
standing up on the boat in a way you
would never stand in a boat even if it
was on dry land and he's looking
gorgeous and wonderful and then you have
a more realistic rendering of what it
was actually a lot like not a boat but a
barge what is the what's important about
those two distinctions
well what's important is we saw the
original picture where he is leaning
forward in this little rowboat in a icy
River and that's absurd but we just
accepted it because he is the leader and
because he's George Washington and would
just say well that's sort of what we
expect leaders to do but no rational
person would do that he wouldn't have
survived the war and he done that and
yet when we picture him more
realistically we say well that doesn't
seem to be consonant with what we think
about heroic you even say because he's
nervous sort of gripping the wheel there
you know I mean holding on tight right
in this more realistic version I'd say
rational began he still looks brave why
is it important at that crucial battle
why is it important as it for those of
us trying to learn about leadership that
we study picture two and not
because we want to believe the mythology
that the leaders 10 feet tall never
scared never wrong has he answered all
our questions that's never correct and
we also tend to think that the leaders
going to solve the problem it's not the
leaders solving the problem it is the
team solving the problem the interaction
between leaders and followers and so
we're much healthier if we pull back a
little bit from the idea that the leader
is all-powerful you say we shouldn't
really talk about how they lied we
should ask how did they emerge as a
leader and that every leader is
different in person it's different in
private than they are in person that's
right the fact is we want to look at
leaders a certain way and we sometimes
discount how they are in private or we
don't understand how they are in private
and sometimes we're very disappointed
when they see how they are in private
because it just doesn't match part of
the mythology we have but the reality is
every person is a human being and so
what we've got to do is look at these
leaders holistically we've got to expect
certain things from them they should
inspire us they should bring values they
should bring the team together they
should do those things that lets us as a
group solve the problem we should not
sit back and wait for the leaders are
not always virtuous to which I thought
was interesting because we always think
our leaders should be have very high
morals and have great character and
great integrity and you said that is not
always the case
well let's it's certainly not if we look
Coco Chanel spent a number of years in
an affair with an odd seal senior
officer almost every one of the leaders
we look at has something that the rest
of us would take significant exception
to did you know Coco Chanel was when we
started the book
I didn't that it's a person I thought
it's just a name on handbags and perfume
so this book educated me significantly
talk about I mean your since your father
served and you went to West Point you
grew up
revering general robert e lee the
confederate journal and just in the past
couple years you threw out a painting
that you've had your entire life what
changed your thinking about him I grew
up right near his home I went to
Washington Lee High School and when I
was a lieutenant my wife gave me this
inexpensive framed picture for 25 bucks
of robert e lee in his uniform and I
kept it
forty years in every home we lived in
and then after Charlotte's failed my
wife pointed out that that's sending a
message you may not want to send and I
said no no he's just a general he he
wasn't political she says he's become
political because people have used his
image for that cause and so I I realized
she was right and I threw it out because
it meant something different than I
wanted it to me yeah and yet when you
look at Robert Ely and you say well he's
if you say he was just a general he was
he was a tremendous soldier for 32 years
in the United States Army he was
probably the most revered officer rising
through the ranks but at the critical
moment of his life he made a decision to
side with the south and to try to
destroy the country that his hero George
Washington helped found and he did it in
defense of slavery now a lot of people
are coming around to your way of
thinking Stan he said we could call him
Stan not general it's it still seems
like general to me you said if you were
rocking a cold war scale if you were
running a company you said you would
hire Martin Luther King jr. that's who
you'd want to lead your company it's
interesting and I didn't expect this
when I read the book certainly we all
loved the cause he was in but reality is
his effectiveness at pulling together
the civil rights cause was extraordinary
cuz he was not an elected leader an
appointed leader he was actually a moral
leader pulling together a bunch of
disparate groups against tremendous
resistance from the south and some
pretty murky political leadership at the
national level
his ability for 12 years to navigate
this from 1955 till he was assassinated
in 1968 is really an extraordinary tale
of leadership and management separate
from what he was leading Issachar that's
a great book my favorite chapters still
about Albert Einstein you said he said
why does everyone love me if they can't
understand me it's a great way to put it
for him because he looks like your uncle
great read thank you so much for joining
us congratulations General Stanley
McChrystal